ukrainian mp inner substance who is in
the kiev region a very warm welcome to
you on sky news describe for us if you
would what you can see taking place
within the capital city
well the situation here is tense we
don't know whether the russians would
actually be able to get into the city it
seems that the ukrainian army is
fighting back they did manage to attack
them on northeast direction and actually
the russian troops did have to surrender
a bit
uh closer to the belarusian border
which does give hope to all of us uh but
still we know that they are not given up
and they can try to gather forces and to
enter the city of kiev regardless of uh
two weeks of uh fruitless attempts to do
so so the situation in kiev despite much
much better than in cities like
archibald particularly mario
it's still tense because we are we have
seen what they're doing to the cities
where they get into and that is indeed
extremely scary so we do have to trust
our army right now that they will
actually manage to keep them on the
entrances to the city and also the city
itself has been very strongly fortified
uh so there are checkpoints it's
extremely difficult to get into the city
so that has given us hope but of course
we do see that the level of cruelty by
the russians is is growing up so
well we have to to get ready for
anything to happen
um the mayor of kiev says that he
believes that they have enough supplies
to hold out for two weeks
yes that uh seems to be uh what has been
happening in the past two weeks
uh the city has been getting prepared
for potential blockade or siege of
course the the supply chains have been
broken
and the main route from the west is now
located by the russians because they do
take did take control of that road from
the west but it seems like uh well there
is enough to survive
uh but of course that all depends on on
whether we shall be able to prevail and
the ukrainian army will manage to kick
them further from them from the capital
uh we again did see some success both in
kia we did see some success in hardkip
where they've been pushed further from
the city
but of course those uh terrible attacks
from here is probably what is most
terrifying because what you are seeing
now on the picture now on the video
those are the results of attack from
here and there is not much ukrainian
army can do unless we do get some
support in terms of protecting our skies
mr klitschko also says that there are
two two million people he believes still
in your capital city and his brother
says that actually people who initially
fled are coming back to try and help
fortify the city
uh well the situation is diverse indeed
some people did flee the city in
different period of times then many
people who got evacuated from the
neighboring cities of european and
butcher they are all actually getting
located in the city as of right now
because uh trevor traveling to the west
is is again complicated uh and again in
the cave city itself it does seem to be
much much uh safer because the air
defense is functioning much better than
in many other areas so people are coming
back uh we do see this trend not just
for the city of kiev but for ukraine
overall we do know that since the first
day of war over 140 000 men returned
from abroad
to fight in the army or in the
territorial defense so this is a general
trend which we hope will help us save
them at least the capital city
and the humanitarian corridors don't
seem to be working have you any hope
that
they can work to get the people out who
want to leave
well they do work with different um
success i would say because clearly the
humanitarian corridor from the city of
maryland are not working every time the
russians are promised in any type of
humanitarian corridor they are either
citing the land land mines there or they
open fire so as of right now people are
not even trying to get into a vacation
corridor from mariupol despite the
situation over there being tragic uh
russians are bombarding the city from
here every 30 minutes and they're
providing not just the hospitals we have
seen they are combining the residential
area so i think that the city of
mariopol is now the biggest victim in
this russian aggression and they're
trying to arrange for a full scale
blockade over there
as for other cities their vacation did
take place from the neighboring cities
of european much and hostile near kiev
not from the first attempt we did have
many previous attempts where the
russians
opened fire on people trying to evacuate
people are vacating in extreme
conditions i did see pictures of people
evacuating by working on on the small
river uh in in in freezing weather
that's how they have to get out of the
cities of european because the
because the the bridge was uh was
destroyed over there
uh but it seems like we did manage to
vacate uh some number of people uh
according to the recent data from the
ukrainian government about 50 000 people
have been evacuated but that's not
nearly nearly enough
of what
we need
and uh particularly in some distance it
is like in the summer it's extremely
difficult to get evacuated and the
russians are always trying to attack
those corridors so people are doing that
you know
it's a gamble for them on their life
and you know i want to ask you um there
are claims fears that russia may be
imminently
about to use chemical weapons
on the people
of ukraine what do people in uh kiev
think about that and how how long how
hopeful are you that you can hold the
capital city
well the chemical weapon is uh is a big
threat we are all extremely concerned uh
the minister of health has been
disseminated information about what you
need to do you know in case of the
chemical attack uh we have another
threat because just about an hour ago
ukrainian intelligence
said that they have information that
russians might try to arrange for some
terrorist attack in the chernobyl
nuclear power station with their which
they are holding from the first day of
the attack
and that would be a threat not just to
the ukrainians there will be threat to
the whole of europe and that is why of
course we are extremely terrified we are
terrified for our lives for the lives of
our loved ones
and and that is why we uh we really hope
that the west will intervene and help us
in that
in terms of securing the no-fly zone so
that we can you know continue fighting
on the ground and possibly pushing them
further into into their borders so that
they will not
attack with chemical weapon and will not
think about arranging some sort of
terrorist attack on the nuclear power
station but the risk is real it's here
we we are going to bed every day
thinking about this and and this is
frankly speaking just terrifying
and in terms of what you want to see
coming from western nations you know i
mean it looks like that you know that
the the no-fly zone isn't going to
happen what realistically
do you think that you can get that you
really need
well we do need a no fly zone it doesn't
change because they are killing us from
air
they do have a superiority in the air
and uh they have superior because they
have much more airplanes but also
because they are abiding our civilian
population there is really very little
we can do in terms of uh helping our
people all over ukraine and they have
bombarding just random cities just this
morning we woke up to the news that they
bombarded
two cities in western ukraine where many
many people from the east have relocated
and then one city in in center east
ukraine and the city of nepal which is a
very big city in the central ukraine
so uh that is still what we need uh we
cannot really win in this war without
support from the air and that's why
we're asking for it so much because if
we have support from the air in any in
any way possible be it by giving us the
fighter jets or giving us the air
defense system that we can operate
ourselves that would be a crucial help
that would actually give us a winning
chance in this terrible terrible war
that we are
that putin launched against us so so
that is still the primary issue in terms
of securing uh the lives of ukrainians
because the second big thing that we
keep on asking is is further
sanctions because uh the sanctions uh um
and i've just heard what you were
reporting about the personal sanctions
we really hope that they would have been
uh
imposed way way earlier and we are happy
that now the united kingdom is thinking
about imposing the sanctions against
people who
voted to support the
recognition of those people's republic
on the east of ukraine but we are also
asking to impose personal sanctions
again against their family members
because their children cannot be studied
in the united kingdom right now that is
not
how it should be their children should
be you know their visas should be
cancelled as well they should go back to
mother russia all their assets of their
children of their family members should
be frozen because we do know that
they're not really you know signing up
their own
bank accounts they have money on the
bank accounts on there of their family
members so we're asking for for
individual sanctions because we believe
that people who are responsible for what
is happening to us for killing
ukrainians for killing our children they
need to have some personal effect in
their own life uh be it uh inability to
travel
frozen assets uh their children not
being able to continue their education
in the united kingdom they should have
some personal consequences because right
now those consequences that uh there are
for russia overall
the people who are directly responsible
are not feeling them for themselves okay
really good of you to share your
thoughts with us um on sky news inner
softson thank you very much thanks for
having me